This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. The week has just begun in Keystone, Iowa. We're here to bear witness to a family meeting. An intervention, if you will. It got kind of rough towards the end of the week, didn't it? We didn't feel like such a family this week. Rachel Cruzey is running this meeting. The other participants are gathered around her in a circle.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。爱荷华州基斯通的一周刚刚开始。我们在这里见证一场家庭会议。或者说，一场干预会议。这周快结束时情况变得有点糟糕，不是吗？我们这周感觉不像一家人。Rachel Cruzey正在主持这场会议。其他参与者围成一圈坐在她周围。
A couple of them fidgeted, but most listen attentively. So on Friday, we decided that today we needed to have a family meeting. Alright, so this weekend I found this book and it's called It's Mine. So when I read this book, I want you to think about how last week went and how this week could go. This family meeting is taking place in a kindergarten classroom in a rural part of Eastern Iowa. Rachel is the teacher, and the lesson she wants to share is one that could have a lasting impact on her students. The story is set on an island.
其中几个人坐立不安，但大多数人都在专心听讲。所以周五我们决定，今天需要开个家庭会议。好了，这个周末我找到了这本书，书名叫《这是我的》。所以当我读这本书时，我希望你们思考一下上周过得怎么样，以及这周可以怎么过。这场家庭会议是在爱荷华州东部农村地区的一间幼儿园教室里举行的。Rachel是老师，她想分享的这堂课可能会对她的学生产生持久的影响。故事发生在一个岛上。
On the island live three Coral Some Frogs named Milton, Ruber and Lydia. They quarreled in quibbles from dawn to dusk. What is it? They said, look, my mind. Stay out of the pond, Yelmilton. The water is mine. What's the water? That's not nice.
岛上住着三只珊瑚蛙，名叫Milton、Ruber和Lydia。他们从早到晚都在争吵。那是什么？他们说，看，那是我的。别进池塘，Milton喊道。水是我的。那水是什么？那太不友好了。
Get off the island, shouted, Ruber. The earth is mine. That's not nice. It's not, is it? Then a flood swallows up the island. There was only one rock left, and there the frogs huddled, trembling from cold and fright. But they felt better now that they were together,
离开这个岛，Ruber喊道。土地是我的。那太不友好了。不是吗？然后一场洪水淹没了这个岛。只剩下一块岩石，青蛙们蜷缩在那里，因寒冷和恐惧而颤抖。但他们现在感到好多了，因为他们在一起了，
sharing the same fears and hopes. Eventually, the sky clears. The frogs swim together, hop after butterflies, and rest in the weeds. We can work together, can't we? Because at the beginning of the story, when they were saying, it's mine, it's mine,
分享着同样的恐惧和希望。最终，天空放晴了。青蛙们一起游泳，追逐蝴蝶，在杂草中休息。我们可以一起工作，不是吗？因为在故事开始时，当他们说“这是我的，这是我的”时，
was anybody having fun? No, no. The kids get it. The frogs are happier when they stop being selfish. This is what it looks like to teach what are sometimes called soft skills. The kind of skills that kids don't get asked about on tests. Of course, Rachel
有人在享受乐趣吗？没有，没有。孩子们明白了。青蛙们停止自私后更快乐了。这就是教授所谓“软技能”的样子。这是孩子们在考试中不会被问到的那种技能。当然，Rachel
teaches the other things you'd expect. Counting, reading and pronunciation, but lessons like this one about the selfish frogs might have the greatest impact. In fact, this impact can actually be quantified in dollars. Today, we have some questions with big implications. Can you put an economic value on a great kindergarten teacher? How is it that two children living just a few blocks from each other can have radically different chances in life? What is it that gives Salt Lake City an edge over Cleveland when it comes to offering people a better life than their parents?
教授你所期望的其他东西。计数、阅读和发音，但像这堂关于自私青蛙的课可能会产生最大的影响。事实上，这种影响实际上可以用美元来量化。今天，我们有一些意义重大的问题。你能给一位优秀的幼儿园老师赋予经济价值吗？为什么两个住在相隔几个街区的孩子在生活中会有截然不同的机会？是什么让盐湖城在为人们提供比父母更好的生活方面比克利夫兰更有优势？
The State of your American Dream, this week on Hidden Brain. The stories we tell about ourselves, stories of success and stories of failure, often have their beginnings in the distant past. Sometimes in our childhoods, sometimes before we were even born. My guest today has explored this idea using hard data drawn from tens of millions of people. It's difficult to describe the range of things he does, except to say that Raj Chetty, an economist at Harvard University, might be the foremost authority today on the state of the American Dream. Raj, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Sean Kurtz. Pleasure to be here.
你的美国梦现状，本周在Hidden Brain。我们讲述的关于自己的故事，成功的故事和失败的故事，往往起源于遥远的过去。有时在我们的童年时期，有时在我们出生之前。我今天的嘉宾利用从数千万人身上提取的硬数据探索了这个想法。很难描述他所做事情的范围，只能说哈佛大学的经济学家Raj Chetty可能是当今美国梦现状方面的首要权威。Raj，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。谢谢你，Shankar。很高兴来到这里。
I want to begin by looking at snapshots in time, Raj, and these are moments from your own life that I think explain a great deal about your work. The first snapshot is when you're by looking at snapshots in time, Raj. And these are moments from your own life that I think explain a great deal about your work. The first snapshot is when you're living in New Delhi in India and you go to see the Taj Mahal. It's a few hours from your home in Delhi. What do you see? Well, it's the first time I've entered the Taj Mahal.
我想从时间快照开始，Raj，这些是你自己生活中的时刻，我认为这些时刻很好地解释了你的工作。第一个快照是你住在印度新德里，去看泰姬陵的时候。离你在德里的家有几个小时的路程。你看到了什么？嗯，这是我第一次进入泰姬陵。
And of course, like everyone, it's overwhelming and it's beauty and how course like everyone, it's overwhelming in its beauty and how impressive of the monument it is. But I think what I was most struck by is after then coming back out of the monument, which was very immaculately kept and maintained, seeing the abject poverty outside the Taj Mahal, people begging for money, kids who don't have clothes who are on the
当然，像每个人一样，它在美感和纪念碑的宏伟程度上令人震撼。但我认为最让我震惊的是，在走出那个维护得非常完美、一尘不染的纪念碑后，看到了泰姬陵外极度的贫困，人们乞讨钱财，没有衣服的孩子在
street, you know, don't have adequate food. Certainly I was exposed to inequality, you know, throughout childhood, but I think this was just such a vivid version of it that stuck in my mind for many years. A couple of years after you visit Taj Mahal, your family immigrates to the United States. You are in a private school in Milwaukee. You play tennis and chess, and so you visit other schools in the area for competitions. What do you see? So a similar experience, actually. So I went to a private school on the north side of Milwaukee called University School,
街上，你知道，没有足够的食物。当然，我在整个童年时期都接触过不平等，但我认为这是一个非常生动的版本，多年来一直留在我的脑海里。在你参观泰姬陵几年后，你的家人移民到了美国。你在密尔沃基的一所私立学校。你打网球和下国际象棋，所以你为了比赛去过该地区的其他学校。你看到了什么？实际上，经历很相似。我去的是密尔沃基北区的一所私立学校，叫大学学校，
and we'd compete with other schools, and as you said, in tennis and chess. And you'd just see, again, the remarkable differences in the physical structure of these schools, so the school that I went to was on something like a 150-acre campus with lots of college level classes. And in contrast, you know, the schools we'd visit were public schools in the city of Milwaukee, which as you might know, these are schools that have faced a lot of challenges. And that was just evident, you know, as a child, seeing the opportunities kids there had
正如你所说，我们会和其他学校在网球和国际象棋上竞争。你会再次看到这些学校在物理结构上的显著差异，所以我去的学校是在一个大约150英亩的校园里，有很多大学水平的课程。相比之下，你知道，我们参观的学校是密尔沃基市的公立学校，正如你可能知道的那样，这些学校面临着很多挑战。作为一个孩子，看到那里的孩子拥有的机会，这显而易见，
talking to them about the types of classes they could take. Again, just really seeing a world with tremendous inequity and wondering, you know, how did I end up in this position? And about these kids who at some level were very similar, were sitting on different sides of the chess board, how did they end up in a different position, in terms of what they had in opportunities? So let's take these ideas from these snapshots, you know, questions related to inequality,
和他们谈论他们可以上的课程类型。同样，真的看到了一个有着巨大不平等的世界，并想知道，你知道，我怎么会处于这个位置？而关于这些在某种程度上非常相似的孩子，坐在棋盘的两边，他们怎么会在拥有的机会方面处于不同的位置？所以，让我们从这些快照中提取这些想法，你知道，与不平等、
to segregation, to opportunity, and dive into some of the research that you've conducted. You once did a study that determined the precise value of having a great kindergarten teacher. Tell me about that study and what the value is that you computed. Yeah, so social scientists have for a long time been studying and been interested in understanding how education affects kids' outcomes. Most prior studies that have been done look at impacts on outcomes like test scores. So if you have
隔离、机会相关的问题，并深入探讨你进行的一些研究。你曾经做过一项研究，确定了一位优秀的幼儿园老师的精确价值。告诉我那个研究以及你计算出的价值。是的，社会科学家长期以来一直在研究并有兴趣了解教育如何影响孩子的结果。大多数之前的研究都着眼于对考试成绩等结果的影响。所以如果你有
a better teacher for instance or if you're in a smaller classroom, do you do better as measured by standardized tests? Now one of the puzzling findings from better earlier work is that you tend to find that if you're in what you might think of as a better classroom, let's take as a concrete example, classroom with a smaller number of kids. You tend to see that kids in those types of classes tend to have higher test scores at the end of that school year, but those gains quickly fade away. So that is if I was in a better kindergarten classroom, I'm doing better at the end of kindergarten, but only a little better at the end of first grade, and by the time I'm in second or third grade, my performance on standardized tests
例如一位更好的老师，或者如果你在一个较小的教室里，你的标准化考试成绩会更好吗？现在，早期研究中一个令人困惑的发现是，你往往会发现，如果你处于你认为更好的教室里，让我们举一个具体的例子，一个学生人数较少的教室。你往往会看到，在这些班级里的孩子在学年结束时往往有更高的考试成绩，但这些收益很快就会消失。也就是说，如果我在一个更好的幼儿园教室里，我在幼儿园结束时表现得更好，但在一年级结束时只好了那么一点点，到了二年级或三年级时，我在标准化考试中的表现
basically looks comparable to other kids who were in different classes. So that, I think, that fade out pattern led to a lot of discouragement among education researchers, saying, saying, oh, it looks like these interventions that we're all studying, reducing class size, trying to improve teacher quality, so forth. They seem to have some impacts, but these impacts don't seem to last. So, you know, is this kind of a blusing cause in the long run? The fade-out effect was discouraging.
基本上看起来和其他在不同班级的孩子相当。所以，我认为这种消失模式导致教育研究人员感到非常沮丧，他们说，哦，看起来我们都在研究的这些干预措施，减少班级规模，试图提高教师素质等等。它们似乎有一些影响，但这些影响似乎并不持久。所以，你知道，从长远来看，这是一种徒劳吗？消失效应令人沮丧。
Maraj had a hunch that maybe the long-term research had not tracked the kids long enough. He found data from an older experiment from Tennessee. The students in this experiment had been randomly assigned to different kindergarten classrooms within their schools. Some had small class sizes of about 15 students. Others were placed in classes that had about 25 students. Rajanis colleagues did something novel with the data to discover the long term, the really long term, effects of kindergarten classrooms on students.
但Raj有一种预感，也许长期研究对孩子们的追踪时间不够长。他从田纳西州的一项旧实验中找到了数据。这项实验中的学生被随机分配到学校内不同的幼儿园教室。一些班级规模较小，约有15名学生。另一些被安置在约有25名学生的班级中。Raj和他的同事对这些数据做了一些新颖的处理，以发现幼儿园教室对学生的长期，真正长期的影响。
We take kind of a big data approach and link the school district records for those 12,000 kids to income tax records and social security records many years later, that basically allow us to ask, how did your earnings, when you're say 25 or 30 years old, vary depending upon which kindergarten classroom you were assigned to? So what this allows you to do is go beyond asking what are the impacts
我们采取了一种大数据方法，将这12,000名孩子的学区记录与多年后的所得税记录和社会保障记录联系起来，这基本上允许我们询问，当你25或30岁时，你的收入如何根据你被分配到的幼儿园教室而变化？所以这让你能够超越询问这些干预措施
of these interventions on test scores and ask what are the impacts on things we actually care about at the end of the day. The types of jobs people end up getting, how much they're earning, whether they go to college or not, and so forth. And what you end up finding in a nutshell is actually quite striking, which is even though you see this fade out pattern that I was describing in terms of test score achievement, the gains actually reemerge in adulthood. The children who were assigned to better teachers, to smaller classes are doing significantly better as adults, showing that early childhood education does in fact have lasting impacts even though curiously those impacts don't seem to last in terms of test scores.
对考试成绩的影响，并询问它们对我们最终真正关心的事物的影响。人们最终得到的工作类型，他们赚多少钱，他们是否上大学等等。简而言之，你最终发现的情况实际上非常惊人，那就是尽管你在考试成绩成就方面看到了我所描述的这种消失模式，但这些收益实际上在成年后又重新出现了。那些被分配到更好的老师、更小班级的孩子在成年后表现得明显更好，这表明幼儿教育确实有持久的影响，尽管奇怪的是，这些影响在考试成绩方面似乎并不持久。
I mean it's a remarkable finding because I think when most of us think about it we sort of say well schooling is important but if you would ask me does what happen in kindergarten affect you when you're 30 years old I would have to say it's probably really marginal but that's not what you're finding. Yeah and it's so to be clear it it is one of many, many different things that matters, right? So I would not say the kindergarten classroom that you're in sort of determines your fate. It's one of a hundred things that influences your outcomes. However, if on average you're assigned to a better teacher or to a smaller class, we see
我的意思是这是一个了不起的发现，因为我认为当我们大多数人思考这个问题时，我们都会说，嗯，学校教育很重要，但如果你问我幼儿园发生的事情是否会在你30岁时影响你，我不得不说这可能真的很微不足道，但那不是你发现的。是的，所以要明确一点，它是许多许多不同重要因素中的一个，对吧？所以我不会说你所在的幼儿园教室决定了你的命运。它是影响你结果的一百件事之一。然而，如果平均而言你被分配到一位更好的老师或更小的班级，我们看到
measurable improvements in children's outcomes on the order of thousands of dollars of earnings per year. And so the kind of quantification of that that we put out in that paper is you can think of having a better kindergarten teacher as being worth something like $300,000 for a classroom of students. That $300,000 figure is an estimate of how much more the kids in the class would earn over their lifetimes. It's the difference between the earnings from a class with a high-quality
儿童结果有可衡量的改善，每年收入增加数千美元。因此，我们在那篇论文中提出的量化结果是，你可以认为拥有一位更好的幼儿园老师对一个班级的学生来说价值约30万美元。这30万美元的数字是对班级里的孩子一生中会多赚多少钱的估计。这是拥有高质量幼儿园老师的班级与拥有普通老师的班级之间的收入差。
kindergarten teacher and a class with an average teacher. While Rogers found a way to quantify the economic value of a great kindergarten teacher, he's found it harder to identify what exactly makes a great kindergarten teacher, he's found it harder to identify what exactly makes a great kindergarten teacher. It turns out that credentials like where a teacher went to college are not very helpful in predicting whether someone's going to be a good teacher. So Raj looked instead at how teachers start their students. It's less about, you know, you're very good at explaining certain mathematical concepts.
虽然Raj找到了量化优秀幼儿园老师经济价值的方法，但他发现很难确定到底是什么让一位老师成为优秀的幼儿园老师。事实证明，像老师去哪里上大学这样的资历对于预测某人是否会成为好老师并没有太大帮助。所以Raj转而观察老师如何引导他们的学生。这与其说，你知道，你非常擅长解释某些数学概念。
And something a little bit more nebulous about how well, for instance, you're able to manage a classroom of small children, some of whom might end up being disruptive. Are you able to keep people focused? Are you able to inspire people? How you go about measuring those things systematically? I think is a very interesting question. And even more importantly, how can we then perhaps train teachers to do better on those dimensions? That would be incredibly valuable. But at the moment, I think the best summary is we don't quite know yet. Let's take with this theory that in some ways what's happening, the difference between
不如说是一些更模糊的东西，关于你如何，例如，能够管理一个由小孩子组成的教室，其中一些人最终可能会具有破坏性。你能够让人们保持专注吗？你能够激励人们吗？你如何系统地去衡量这些事情？我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题。更重要的是，我们如何才能训练老师在这些维度上做得更好？那将是非常有价值的。但目前，我认为最好的总结是我们还不太清楚。让我们带着这个理论，在某种程度上，正在发生的事情，优秀老师和不太优秀老师之间的区别
the great teacher and the not so great teacher might not necessarily be, you know, as one teacher better at teaching the alphabet or teaching the children to count numbers. But it's communicating something else. Something else that actually has, you know, not necessarily immediate benefits in the next year or two, but actually has potentially large benefits over the course of a lifetime. What kind of skills might those be? Yeah, so I think, you know, examples of those kinds of skills might be what we'd call non-cognitive skills or sometimes are called soft skills. So not the, you know, are you able to do what's measured commonly on standardized tests, but rather how well do you get along
可能不一定是，你知道，一位老师更擅长教字母表或教孩子们数数。但它是在传达别的东西。别的东西实际上，你知道，不一定在接下来的一两年内有直接的好处，但实际上在整个生命过程中有潜在的巨大好处。那会是什么样的技能？是的，所以我认为，你知道，这些技能的例子可能是我们所说的非认知技能，或者有时被称为软技能。所以不是，你知道，你是否能够做标准化考试中通常衡量的东西，而是你与他人相处得有多好，你有多自律，你有多专注？所以这不仅仅是猜测。事实上，作为这项研究的一部分，我们有一些证据支持这种推理。所以事实证明，在这个田纳西州STAR实验中，他们让这些八年级的学生让他们的老师对他们进行28种不同非认知技能指标的评分。
with others and how disciplined are you, how focused are you? So that's not just speculation. In fact, as part of this study, we have some evidence that supports exactly that kind of reasoning. So it turns out in this Tennessee star experiment, they took these students in eighth grade and had their teachers rate them on 28 different measures of non-cognitive skills.
所以询问他们，老师，这个学生是否与同龄人相处融洽？学生是否能够集中注意力等等？真正有趣的是，那些拥有更好幼儿园教室的学生，他们在这些非认知指标上的得分明显更高。所以你看到了在这些非认知维度上持续至少八年的持久收益。而且，如果你看看什么与成年后的后期结果相关性更强，
So asking them, the teacher, does this student get along well with his or her peers? Is the student able to concentrate and so forth? And what's really interesting is that the students who had better kindergarten classrooms, they score significantly higher on these non-cognitive measures. So you're seeing persistent gains that last for at least eight years on these non-cognitive dimensions. And moreover, if you look at what correlates more strongly with later outcomes in adulthood,
比如收入、就业率、大学入学率，实际上这些非认知指标比我们倾向于关注的传统认知技能更具预测性。也就是说，如果我问什么更能预测你将赚多少钱，是与同龄人相处融洽的人，还是在数学考试中得分很高的人，是那个与他人相处融洽的人
like earnings, employment rates, college attendance, it's actually these non-cognitive measures that are more predictive than the traditional cognitive skills that we tend to focus on. That is, if I ask which is more predictive of how much you will earn, someone who gets along well with their peers or someone who scores very high on math tests, it's the person who gets along with other people
平均而言在成年后做得更好。将所有这些证据放在一起，我的解读是，早期的环境和教室、老师等等之所以重要，不是因为你正在学习的技术技能，而是因为这套在劳动力市场上有巨大回报的更广泛的技能。当我们回来时，我们将从教室转向社区。你居住的社区如何成为成功的引擎或对你抱负的阻碍。
that on average is doing better in adulthood. Putting all those pieces of evidence together, my reading is the early environments and classrooms, teachers and so on matter not because of the technical skills you're learning, but because of this broader set of skills that have big payoffs in the labor market. When we come back, we move from classrooms to neighborhoods. How the neighborhood you live in can be an engine for success or a break on your ambitions.
这是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。美国的故事中嵌入了一个核心信念。这个想法是，如果你愿意努力工作，你是谁，你来自哪里，或者你看起来像什么并不重要。我们将共同创造一个开放的美国，让每个公民都能获得美国梦。美国梦，这个任何人都有可能攀登经济阶梯并拥有稳定繁荣生活的想法，这个想法代代相传。一个梦想，一个地方，在那里一个普通人可以为自己建设，并把他的孩子抚养到更好的
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's a core belief that's embedded in the story of America. The idea that if you're willing to work hard, it doesn't matter who you are, or where you come from, or what you look like. And together we will create an America that is open so every citizen has access to the American dream. The American dream, this idea that it's possible for anyone to climb the economic ladder and have a stable prosperous life, this idea has endured across generations. A dream of a place where a pre-man could build for himself and raise his children to a better
生活。那个梦想是美国的心脏和灵魂。它是让我们的国家永远善良和慷慨的承诺。但越来越多的人开始质疑这个梦想是否还有可能。共和党人和民主党人都认为美国梦正在瓦解。美国梦已死。你和我可能是美国历史上第一代看到我们的孩子比我们做得更差的人。Raj Chetty说，与50年前相比，美国的经济流动性已经下降。
life. That dream is the heart and soul of America. It's the promise that keeps our nation forever good and generous. But increasingly, many people have come to question whether this dream is possible anymore. Both Republicans and Democrats have argued the American dream is unraveling. The American dream is dead. You and I may be the first generation in American history to see our kids do worse than we did. Raj Chetty says economic mobility has fallen in the US compared to 50 years ago.
今天，比父母做得更好的人要少得多。但当你仔细观察数据时，出现的图景要微妙得多。所以考虑一下经典“白手起家”概念背景下的向上流动性。假设你是一个在低收入家庭长大的孩子，比如收入分配的后五分之一，你达到前五分之一的几率是多少
Far fewer people today are doing better than their parents. But when you take a close look at the data, the picture that emerges is much more nuanced. So think about upward mobility in the context of the classic crags to Richard's kind of notion. Suppose you're a kid growing up in a low-income family, say the bottom fifth of the income distribution, what are your odds of reaching the top fifth
收入分配，实现从底层到顶层的飞跃？事实证明，如果你看整个美国，这个数字是7.5%，7.5%的从相对低收入家庭开始的孩子最终会达到前五分之一。但如果你然后分解这些数据并询问，这如何根据你成长的州
of the income distribution, making that leap from the bottom to the top? So it turns out if you look at the US as a whole, that number is seven and a half percent, seven and a half percent of kids who start out in a relatively low income family will end up reaching the top fifth on average. But if you then break that data down and ask, how does that vary depending upon which state
或你成长的县而变化？你会发现它实际上变化很大。所以在美国的某些地区，例如，在爱荷华州农村或大平原的大部分地区，或像盐湖城或旧金山这样的某些城市，例如，在爱荷华州农村或大平原的大部分地区，或像盐湖城或旧金山这样的某些城市，例如，你从后五分之一上升到前五分之一的几率大约是14%或15%，是全国平均水平的两倍。相比之下，如果你看光谱的另一端，看看像北卡罗来纳州夏洛特、佐治亚州亚特兰大，或者更广泛地说美国东南部的大部分地区，或者像底特律这样的工业中西部地区
or which counter you're growing up in? You see that actually varies dramatically. So in certain parts of the U.S. for example, in rural Iowa or much of the great plains or certain cities like Salt Lake City or San Francisco for example, in rural Iowa or much of the great plains or certain cities like Salt Lake City or San Francisco, for example, your odds of rising from the bottom fifth to the top fifth are something like 14 or 15 percent, twice as high as the national average. In contrast, if you look at the other end of the spectrum, look at cities like Charlotte, North Carolina, Atlanta, Georgia, or more generally much of the southeastern United States, or places in the industrial midwest like Detroit
或克利夫兰，你从底层上升到顶层的几率低于5%，有时甚至只有3.5%或4%。现在，我刚才提到的那些差异，它们相当大。它们基本上是在说，对于一个特定的孩子，如果你恰好在一个地方成长，你进入中产阶级或中上阶级的几率比在另一个地方高两到三倍。所以我经常说，人们问，你知道，美国梦今天还活着吗？我实际上认为这个问题本身提得不太好，
or Cleveland, your odds of rising from the bottom to the top are below 5%, sometimes even only 3.5% or 4%. Now, those differences that I just mentioned, they're quite substantial. They're basically saying that for a given child, your odds of making it to the middle class or to the upper middle class are two or three times higher if you happen to be growing up in one place relative to another. And so what I often say is people ask, you know, is the American dream alive or not today? And I actually think the question itself is sort of ill posed,
“美国梦”这个词，我们真的应该把它看作是“爱荷华梦”或“亚特兰大梦”或“加州梦”，因为这个国家内部有太多的差异。所以这项工作的一个重大见解在某种程度上是，与其看整个国家，不如看这些大都市区或城市实际上更有用，因为在某种程度上，它们描绘了非常不同的图景。但在你最近的工作中，你实际上更进一步说，你实际上可以在城市内部寻找，并找到关于向上流动性状况的更细致的
the term the American dream, really we should think of it as the Iowa dream or the Atlanta dream or the California dream, because there's so much variation within this country. So one of the big insights of this work in some ways is that rather than looking at the nation as a whole, it's actually useful to look at these metropolitan areas or cities because in some ways they paint very different pictures. But in your most recent work, you've actually taken this a step further and said, you can actually look within cities and find even more granular
细节。跟我谈谈这项工作。是的，完全正确。随着我们在这项工作上的进展，我们采取了一种越来越细致的地理层面的方法。所以亚特兰大与盐湖城或旧金山的对比，我认为很有趣。但更让我们惊讶的是，如果我看看亚特兰大内部，或者如果我看看洛杉矶内部，事实证明你基本上可以看到你在
details about the state of upward mobility. Talk to me about this work. Yeah, that's exactly right. So as we've been proceeding on this work, we've been taking the approach of kind of going to finer and finer levels of geography. So the Atlanta versus Salt Lake City or San Francisco contrast, I think, is interesting. But what was even more surprising to us is if I look within Atlanta, or if I look within Los Angeles, turns out you can essentially see the same amount of variation that you see
整个美国看到的相同程度的差异，当你观察一个城市内几英里范围时。所以再举几个具体的例子，让我们专注于洛杉矶市作为一个案例。所以许多人熟悉洛杉矶的某些社区，比如康普顿和瓦茨，几十年来一直被称为犯罪率高、贫困率高、由于各种结构性因素导致结果不利的艰难地区。现在我们展示了在这些特定社区长大的孩子，例如，在瓦茨长大的孩子，
in the U.S. as a whole, when you look within a few miles in a given city. So to give you some specific examples again, let's focus on the city of Los Angeles to take one case. So many people are familiar with certain neighborhoods in Los Angeles like Compton and Watts, which have been known for many decades to be tough areas with high rates of crime, high rates of poverty, and adverse outcomes due to various structural factors. Now we show that kids who grow up in those specific neighborhoods, so for instance, kids who grow up in Watts,
特别是那些在该地区长大的黑人男性，有着非常不利的结果。例如，在瓦茨低收入家庭长大的黑人男性，平均而言，在30多岁时每年的收入只有7,000美元。这就是平均水平，对吧？所以这意味着绝大多数这些男性的收入非常接近于零。他们没有工作等等。另一个有点令人震惊的统计数据，在那个特定普查区长大的黑人男性在任何特定日子里被监禁的几率大约是45%，这意味着他们一生中被监禁的几率要高得多，
and black men in particular who grow up in that area, have very adverse outcomes. So for example, black men who grow up in low-income families in Watts, on average, have earnings of only $7,000 a year in their mid-30s. And that is the average, right? So that means that the vast majority of these men have incomes very close to zero. They're not working and so forth. Another somewhat shocking statistic, black men growing up in that particular census tract have something like a 45% chance of being incarcerated on any given day, which means that their lifetime chance of ever being incarcerated is much higher,
你知道，很可能是70%或80%。你是在任何特定日子里看到的吗？在某一天，在某一天，2010年人口普查的数据，在被称为尼克森花园公共住房项目的瓦茨地区长大的黑人男性中，45%的人被监禁。这是一个关于，我的意思是，美国，我认为，我们有如此高的监禁率，在某些情况下，但这是关于那个地区的一个事实。
you know, could well be something like 70 or 80%. Did you see on any given day? On a given day, on a given day, the date of the 2010 census, 45% of the black men who grew up in this tract in what's called the Nickerson Gardens Public Housing Project. 45% of them are incarcerated. It's a shocking statement about, I mean, the United States, I think, that we have such high levels of incarceration in certain cases, but that is a fact about that tract.
现在，你知道，在某种程度上对于住在洛杉矶的人来说，可能对那个程度感到震惊，但可能对在该地区长大的孩子有非常不利的结果这一事实并不感到惊讶。不过，这里可能有一些你不知道的事情。如果你去一两英里外的康普顿，你会看到在那里长大的黑人男性的监禁率，
Now, you know, in some level for people living in LA, maybe shocked by that magnitude, but maybe not surprised by the fact that they're very adverse outcomes for kids growing up in that area. Here's maybe something you didn't know, though. If you go a mile or two away to Compton, you see that rates of incarceration for black men growing up there,
收入相当的家庭，大约是6%。所以实际上仍然很高，6%不是一个小数字，但相对于45%，它要低得多。这就是为什么当你查看这些地图时，我们以交互式工具的形式发布了这些地图，你可以查看你自己的地址，查看美国的任何社区，70,000个不同的社区将这些城市中的每一个拆分为不同的区域，你会看到在很短的距离内这种巨大的差异。
families of comparable income, or something like 6%. So still actually high, 6% is not a small number, but relative to 45%, it's dramatically lower. And so that's the sense in which when you look at these maps, which we've put out in the form of an interactive tool where you can look at your own address, look at any neighborhood in the United States, 70,000 different neighborhoods splitting up each of these cities into different areas, you see this tremendous variation across very short distances.
对于在收入相当、种族背景相同的家庭中长大的孩子来说，你在哪里成长似乎真的很重要。你在哪里成长似乎真的很重要。问题是，为什么？是什么解释了盐湖城和夏洛特之间的差异？所以我们还不知道到底是什么配方可以在一个地方产生比另一个地方更好的结果，但我们已经研究了经济学家和社会学家多年来谈论的各种不同因素，这些因素可能驱动
For kids who grow up in families with comparable income, same racial background, where you're growing up really seems to matter. Where you grow up really seems to matter. The question is, why? What explains the difference between Salt Lake City and Charlotte? So we don't know yet exactly what is the recipe to produce better outcomes in one place relative to another, but we've looked at a variety of different factors that economists and sociologists have talked about over the years as potentially driving differences
结果的差异。我们已经确定了五六个似乎是这些差异的强预测因素的不同事物。所以第一个是隔离。所以那些按种族或收入隔离程度更高的城市，黑人和白人互动不多，或者低收入和高收入家庭
in outcomes. And we've identified five or six different things that really seem like strong predictors of these differences. So the first is segregation. So cities that are more segregated by race or by income, where blacks and whites are not interacting as much or low income and high income families
生活在彼此分离的地方。像那样的隔离地方往往对所有种族和族裔群体的人来说结果都更差，所以这是数据中的一个强烈模式。Raj发现，在拥有较小中产阶级的地区，向上流动性不太常见。他还注意到一些其他模式。我们发现这些结果与社区中的家庭结构指标之间存在非常强的关联。所以特别是在数据中最强的模式之一是，更多孩子由双亲家庭抚养的地区往往有更高的向上流动率。现在，在解释这种相关性时，
are living separated from each other. Segregated places like that tend to have much worse outcomes for people of all racial and ethnic groups, so that's one strong pattern in the data. Raj has found that upward mobility is less common in places that have a smaller middle class. He's also noticed some other patterns. We find that there's a very strong association between these outcomes and measures of family structure in a neighborhood. So in particular one of the strongest patterns in the data is that areas where more kids are raised by two parent families tend to have higher rates of upward mobility. Now in interpreting that correlation it's very
非常重要的是要注意，它不是由你自己在一个双亲家庭中成长会导致特定孩子有更好结果这一事实机械驱动的。我们发现的是，即使你自己的父母已婚，如果你在一个很多孩子由单亲抚养的地区长大，你攀登收入阶梯的可能性就较小。所以这向你展示的是，这不是你父母婚姻状况的直接影响。它再次是关于社区层面的因素，
important to note that it's not mechanically driven by the fact that growing up yourself in a two-parent family leads to better outcomes for a given kid. What we find is, even if your own parents are married, if you grow up in an area where a lot of kids are being raised by single parents, you are less likely to climb the income ladder. So what that shows you is, this is not the direct effect of your own parents' marital status. It's again something about community level factors that
这些因素与一个地区单亲家庭的比例相关，这可以预测孩子的结果。现在，与此有些相关的是社会资本的概念，这是我的哈佛同事Bob Putnam推广的一个概念，我认为“抚养一个孩子需要一个村庄”这句古老的谚语是思考社会资本是什么的一种方式。即使你做得不好，别人会帮你一把吗？
are associated with the fraction of single parents in an area that's predictive of kids' outcomes. Now, somewhat related to that is the idea of social capital, a concept popularized by my Harvard colleague, Bob Putnam, I think of the old adage that it takes a village to raise a child as a way to think about what social capital is. Will someone else help you out even if you're not doing well?
拥有摩门教的盐湖城被认为是拥有大量社会资本的城市的典型例子，相应地也有很高的向上流动率。因此，据我们所能衡量的，我们发现拥有更高社会资本的地方往往有更高的向上流动率。最后，我再提一个，回到我们关于学校的讨论，正如你可能预料的那样，直觉上拥有更好学校的地方往往有更高的向上流动率。我认为这种联系特别值得注意，
Salt Lake City with the Mormon Church is thought to be a canonical example of a city with a lot of social capital, and correspondingly has high rates of upward mobility. And so, as best we can measure it, we find that places with higher lot of social capital and correspondingly has higher rates of upward mobility. And so, as best we can measure it, we find that places with higher levels of social capital tend to have higher levels of upward mobility. And then finally, I'll mention one last one, coming back to our discussion about schools, as you might expect, intuitively places that have better schools tend to have higher rates of upward mobility. And I think that connection is particularly important to note,
因为学校是我认为清楚地属于政策领域的东西，我们也许能够弄清楚如何做出改变以提高学校的质量。我一直在描述的其他一些因素，虽然我认为它们非常重要，值得研究，也很有趣，但很难弄清楚你该做什么
because schools are something that I think fall clearly in the policy domain where we might be able to figure out how to make changes to improve the quality of schools. Some of the other factors I've been describing, while I think they're very important to study and interesting to understand, it's harder to figure out what do you do
来尝试改变一个地区的社会资本或家庭结构，我认为这有点复杂，至少从政策角度来看是这样。所以Raj已经确定，你在哪里成长以及你上的学校类型会对你的生活产生很大影响。所以显而易见的政策含义是，将人们从结果较差的地区转移到结果较好的地方。在20世纪90年代，联邦政府用一个名为“搬迁至机会”的项目测试了这个想法。这是早间版。
to try to change social capital or family structures in an area That's I think a little bit more complicated at least to figure out from a policy point of view So Raj is established that where you grow up and the kind of school you attend can make a big difference in your life So the obvious policy implication is Move people from areas where outcomes are worse, to places where outcomes are better. In the 1990s, the federal government tested this very idea with a program called Moving to Opportunity. This is morning edition.
我是Bob Edwards。联邦政府正在进行一项实验。它正在帮助来自五个城市的穷人搬进中产阶级社区。志愿者家庭被从洛杉矶、波士顿、纽约、芝加哥和巴尔的摩的困难地区转移出来。在租金补贴的帮助下，这些家庭搬到了更富裕的地区，通常是在郊区。非常像关于优秀幼儿园老师影响的研究，搬迁至机会实验的结果令人失望。
I'm Bob Edwards. The federal government is conducting an experiment. It's helping poor people from five cities move into middle-class neighborhoods. Volunteer families were transferred out of troubled sections of Los Angeles, Boston, New York, Chicago, and Baltimore. With the help of rent subsidies, the families moved to more affluent areas, often in the suburbs. Very much like the studies on the effects of great kindergarten teachers, the results from the moving to opportunity experiment were underwhelming.
但Raj做了他用课堂研究做过的完全相同的事情。他询问研究人员是否足够长久地研究了这个项目的影响。搬迁至机会研究在某种程度上是该领域的一项里程碑式研究，因为它说，让我们采取科学实验的视角。我们有一些证据表明结果在这些社区之间似乎有所不同。让我们走出去，通过给他们提供不同社区的代金券，真正随机地分配家庭，看看结果是否不同。
But Raj did exactly what he had done with the classroom studies. He asked where the researchers had studied the effects of this program long enough. The moving to opportunity study was in some ways a landmark study in this field because it said, let's take the perspective of a scientific experiment. We have some evidence where it looks like outcomes vary across these neighborhoods. And let's just go out there and really randomly assign families effectively by giving them vouchers to different neighborhoods and see if outcomes differ.
而且我认为当时参与该研究的每个人都期待看到你会发现对人们结果的真正巨大和直接的影响，这将表明环境确实很重要，我们将从那里开始发展经济适用房政策等等。非常令人失望的是，最初的研究，其中有很多，几乎一致表明搬迁至机会没有产生任何真正可检测到的经济影响。当然，在成年人的健康和其他我们关心的维度上确实有改善，关于人们感觉有多抑郁的报告，甚至糖尿病发病率的指标，
And I think everyone who was involved in that study at that point was expecting to see that you'd find really big and immediate impacts on people's outcomes, and this would show that environment really matters, and we would go from there and developing affordable housing policy and so forth. And very disappointingly, the initial studies, and there were many of these, almost uniformly showed that moving to opportunity had no real detectable economic impact. There were to be clear improvements in the health of adults and other dimensions that we care about, reports of how depressed people were feeling or even indicators of rates of diabetes,
诸如此类的事情，你确实在那里看到了变化，但在经济结果、就业率、收入等方面，并没有发现太大的影响。现在，所有这些最初的研究都在观察搬迁至机会对成年人或相对年长的孩子的影响。他们在搬迁时处于青少年时期。这有一个非常简单的原因。人们急于评估干预措施的结果。
things like that, you did see changes there, but in terms of economic outcomes, employment rates, earnings, and so forth, didn't find much of an effect. Now, all of those initial studies were looking at the impacts of moving to opportunity on adults or kids who were relatively old. They were in their teens at the point of the move. And there was a very simple reason for that. People were eager to evaluate the results of the intervention.
当然，你不能在20世纪90年代中期实验点之后很快观察到幼儿的结果，因为孩子们长大然后看到他们的收入和成年期等等需要时间。所以我们所做的是呼应，你知道，我们之前谈到的田纳西州STAR实验的一些主题。我们回到了搬迁至机会数据，将其与税务记录联系起来，以便能够更长时间地追踪人们。我们在研究中有一个非常明确的假设，也许人们在搬迁至机会数据中没有发现影响的原因是环境产生影响需要时间。并不是说我只是
And of course, you couldn't look at young kids' outcomes very quickly after the point of the experiment in the mid-1990s because it would take time for the kids to grow up and then see their earnings and adulthood and so forth. So what we did is echoing, you know, some of the themes actually of what we talked about earlier with the Tennessee Star experiment. we went back to the Moving to Opportunity Data, linked that to tax records in order to be able to track people over a longer period of time. And we had a very clear hypothesis going into the study that maybe the reason people hadn't found effects in the Moving to Opportunity Data is that it takes time for environment to have an impact. It's not that I just
帮助你搬到一个不同的社区，明天你最终就会有完全不同的结果。相反，它与接触有关。你可能需要在某个地方成长很长时间才能真正看到可衡量的变化。所以当我们回到数据中时，我们发现非常显著的是，这正是正在发生的事情。如果你看看那些相对年轻的孩子，比如在他们作为实验一部分搬迁时低于12岁，你会看到由于搬迁到贫困程度较低、中产阶级的社区而产生的相当大的收益，收入增加了约30%，大学入学率增加了30%，青少年生育率降低了25%，所以在各种结果上，都有相当大的收益。
help you move to a different neighborhood and tomorrow you end up having completely different outcomes. Rather, it's related to exposure. You have to spend a lot of time perhaps growing up in a given place in order to see really see measurable changes. And so what we found when we went back to the data is remarkably that that's exactly what's going on. If you look at kids who were relatively young, say below age 12 at the point that they moved as part of this experiment, you see quite substantial gains as a result of moving to a lower poverty, middle class neighborhood, something like a 30% increase in earnings, 30% increase in college attendance rates, 25% reduction in the rate of having a teenage birth, so on a variety of outcomes, quite substantial gains.
帮助你搬到一个不同的社区，而明天你最终会得到完全不同的结果。相反，这与接触有关。你可能需要在某个地方成长很长一段时间，才能真正看到可衡量的变化。因此，当我们回顾数据时，我们发现的情况非常引人注目，这正是正在发生的事情。如果你看看那些相对年轻的孩子，比如在参与这项实验时搬家时不到12岁，你会发现搬到贫困程度较低的中产阶级社区会带来相当大的收益，收入增加了约30%，大学入学率增加了30%，青少年生育率降低了25%，因此在各种结果上，收益相当可观。
But if you do the exact same analysis for kids who moved at older ages, you see essentially no gain at all. And if you look at adults who moved as part of the experiment, verifying what earlier studies found, we see no gains at all. And so what that's very consistent with is the idea that there's sort of a dosage effect. Or every extra year you spend growing up in a better neighborhood helps you in the long run, but those effects really accumulate to something we're able to detect in the data only if people move young enough. If there is one theme that emerges from this kind of analysis, it is about the value of nuances. It is true that geography and education matter, but there are also social factors that have independent effects. A big one, race.
但如果你对在较大年龄搬家的孩子进行完全相同的分析，你会发现几乎没有任何收益。如果你观察那些作为实验一部分而搬家的成年人，验证了早期研究的发现，我们发现根本没有任何收益。这与“剂量效应”的观点非常一致。也就是说，你在更好的社区成长的每多一年，从长远来看都会对你有帮助，但只有当人们在足够年轻时搬家，这些影响才会真正积累到我们在数据中能够检测到的程度。如果说这种分析中出现了一个主题，那就是细微差别的价值。地理位置和教育确实很重要，但也有一些社会因素具有独立的影响。其中一个重要的因素是种族。
Neighborhoods matter, but they're certainly not everything. I mean, I want to be very clear about that. And so race is a very good example where it illustrates that you shouldn't think about neighborhoods as being an environmental set of factors that applies to everyone equally. When we break the data down by race, we find very stark differences. In particular, between black and white men, growing up in a given neighborhood, for women, there actually aren't very large differences in rates of upward or downward mobility between black and white women. But for black versus white men, you see really stark differences in rates of mobility. A black man and a white man who grew up in families with comparable income, living on the
社区很重要，但它们肯定不是全部。我的意思是，我想把这一点说得很清楚。种族就是一个很好的例子，它说明了你不应该把社区看作是适用于所有人的环境因素集合。当我们按种族细分数据时，我们发现了非常明显的差异。特别是黑人男性和白人男性之间，在同一个社区长大，对于女性来说，黑人女性和白人女性在向上或向下流动率方面实际上并没有很大的差异。但对于黑人男性和白人男性，你会看到流动率方面存在非常明显的差异。一个黑人男性和一个白人男性，他们在收入相当的家庭中长大，住在
same block, both two parent families, similar levels of education, similar levels of wealth. So basically control for all the family level factors that you can sort of think of. You still see that the black man has much lower chances of climbing the income ladder than white men. And perhaps even more alarmingly, black men have much higher rates of downward mobility than white men. If you're born to an affluent family as a black man, you are much more likely to fall down the income ladder than white men are, who tend to persist near the top of the income distribution. The way I like to think about it is,
同一个街区，都是双亲家庭，受教育程度相似，财富水平相似。所以基本上控制了你能想到的所有家庭层面的因素。你仍然会看到，黑人男性攀登收入阶梯的机会比白人男性低得多。也许更令人担忧的是，黑人男性的向下流动率比白人男性高得多。如果你作为一个黑人男性出生在一个富裕家庭，你比白人男性更有可能从收入阶梯上跌落，而白人男性往往会保持在收入分配的顶端附近。我喜欢这样思考这个问题：
if you think about upward mobility as climbing an income ladder for white men, it's more like being on a treadmill for black men. Even after you climb up in one generation, you tend to fall back down in the next generation. And that's true, even among two kids who grew up in the same neighborhood, who go to the same school and so forth.
如果你把向上流动看作是白人男性的攀登收入阶梯，那么对于黑人男性来说，这更像是在跑步机上。即使你在这一代人中向上攀登，你在下一代人中往往又会跌落回来。即使是两个在同一个社区长大、上同一所学校等等的孩子，情况也是如此。
So this presents obviously a puzzle. If you have two families, one black, one white, they both have a son and a daughter. What you're saying is, on average, the white boy is going to do significantly better than the black boy, but the white girl isn't going to do significantly better than the black girl. How do you explain this? Again, I think the explanation is something that remains to be fully resolved, but I can give you some sense of what we think might be going on. So when we then use this neighborhood level data, this granular information, you can go and ask, are there some places in America where we actually see black men doing relatively well, and what might be able to learn from those examples? So it turns out you can look at certain places silver spring in Maryland for example. More generally they're scattered set of areas across the
所以这显然提出了一个难题。如果你有两个家庭，一个是黑人，一个是白人，他们都有一个儿子和一个女儿。你的意思是，平均而言，白人男孩的表现将明显好于黑人男孩，但白人女孩的表现不会明显好于黑人女孩。你如何解释这一点？同样，我认为这个解释还有待完全解决，但我可以让你了解一下我们认为可能发生了什么。所以当我们使用这种社区层面的数据，这种细粒度的信息时，你可以去问，在美国是否有一些地方我们实际上看到黑人男性的表现相对较好，我们能从这些例子中学到什么？事实证明，你可以看看某些地方，例如马里兰州的银泉。更广泛地说，它们是分散在
United States where you see relatively good outcomes for black men. And they tend to have three characteristics which I think shed some light on why these gaps prevail for men rather than women. So first, we find that these places tend to have relatively low poverty rates, so they have good resources. Second, as you might expect intuitively, they have low levels of racial bias among whites. We find that places with less racial bias have relatively good outcomes for black men, relative to white men. And then the third factor we identify is that areas with high rates of father presence where lots of kids, again, are being raised in two parent families, and in particular black kids are being raised in two parent families, they tend to have particularly good outcomes for black boys,
美国各地的一些区域，在那里你可以看到黑人男性的表现相对较好。它们往往具有三个特征，我认为这些特征揭示了为什么这些差距在男性而非女性中普遍存在。首先，我们发现这些地方的贫困率往往相对较低，因此它们拥有良好的资源。其次，正如你凭直觉所预料的那样，白人对种族的偏见程度较低。我们发现，种族偏见较少的地方，黑人男性相对于白人男性的表现相对较好。我们确定的第三个因素是，父亲在场率高的地区，即许多孩子再次在双亲家庭中被抚养长大，特别是黑人孩子在双亲家庭中被抚养长大，他们往往对黑人男孩有特别好的结果，
relative to white boys. Now, importantly, that last correlation that I mentioned, that's true only for black boys. When black girls grow up in an area with greater presence of fathers, their outcomes look pretty similar. And so coming back to your question, what is driving these gender disparities? My sense from this data, while it's not conclusive, it suggests that environmental factors
相对于白人男孩。现在，重要的是，我提到的最后一个相关性，只适用于黑人男孩。当黑人女孩在父亲在场率较高的地区长大时，她们的结果看起来非常相似。所以回到你的问题，是什么导致了这些性别差异？根据这些数据，虽然不是决定性的，但我的感觉是，环境因素
are amplifying these disparities for black men in particular. When we come back, how Raj's insights can be applied to policy. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Raj Chetty has spent years mining vast troves of data to understand economic mobility and inequality in the United States. Increasingly, Raj and his team are moving from analysis to action.
正在放大黑人男性的这些差异。回来后，拉杰的见解如何应用于政策。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。拉杰·切蒂花了很多年挖掘海量数据，以了解美国的经济流动性和不平等。拉杰和他的团队正越来越多地从分析转向行动。
They're asking how the insights they have generated might improve, for example, the quality of education. My big picture take is we should be doing everything we can to try to have the best teachers in American classrooms. And I think the systems that we currently have in place for various reasons don't really achieve that goal. So in most professions in the United States, if you're generating a lot of value for your company, people are going to be able to make changes to try to keep you, right? So you might get a pay raise, you might get a different portfolio of what you have to manage,
他们正在询问他们产生的见解如何能够改善，例如，教育质量。我的总体看法是，我们应该尽我们所能，努力让美国课堂拥有最好的老师。我认为我们目前实施的系统由于各种原因并没有真正实现这一目标。因此，在美国的大多数职业中，如果你为你的公司创造了大量价值，人们将能够做出改变来试图留住你，对吧？所以你可能会加薪，你可能会得到一个不同的管理组合，
you might get a promotion in various ways. In most schools, salaries are basically set in lockstep to experience, with no ability for the principles to have discretion to give teachers a bonus if they're doing extremely well or try to give a retention package to a teacher who was really attractive offer from a private school or from a totally different employer. So I think creating a little bit more of that flexibility to retain and recruit top talent in teaching, just like we do in the rest of the economy in the United States,
你可能会以各种方式获得晋升。在大多数学校，工资基本上是与经验挂钩的，校长没有能力酌情给表现非常好的老师发奖金，或者试图给一个从私立学校或完全不同的雇主那里得到非常有吸引力录用通知的老师提供留任方案。所以我认为创造更多这种灵活性来留住和招聘顶尖的教学人才，就像我们在美国其他经济领域所做的那样，
could be incredibly valuable. But I think, you know, more broadly, what I see as the broader problem is teaching is often not viewed as the first profession you'd choose to pursue if you're a really talented kid in the United States. And I think that's really not a good state of affairs. Countries that have excellent educational systems that people point to Finland, for example, you often hear that kids' aspiration if they're doing really well in school is to become a teacher.
可能非常有价值。但我认为，你知道，更广泛地说，我认为更广泛的问题是，如果你是一个在美国非常有天赋的孩子，教学往往不是你选择追求的第一职业。我认为这真的不是一个好的状况。人们指出的拥有优秀教育系统的国家，例如芬兰，你经常听到，如果孩子们在学校表现非常好，他们的愿望就是成为一名教师。
And so given the importance of teaching as we've established for kids' longterm outcomes broadly, I think it's extremely important that it's viewed as a high status, very desirable profession to go into. I want to spend a moment just talking about the caution that might be needed in terms of sort of applying policy solutions. So for example, you'll find that when really good teachers move into some schools, they have measurable effects, they raise the test scores of students, and over time, this has measurable effects on the long-term outcomes of those students. So you would say, we should actually try and get the teachers who can boost test scores.
因此，考虑到我们已经确定的教学对孩子长期结果的重要性，我认为将其视为一种高地位、非常令人向往的职业是非常重要的。我想花一点时间谈谈在应用政策解决方案方面可能需要的谨慎。例如，你会发现，当非常优秀的老师进入一些学校时，他们会有可衡量的影响，他们提高了学生的考试成绩，随着时间的推移，这对这些学生的长期结果产生了可衡量的影响。所以你会说，我们实际上应该尝试找到那些能够提高考试成绩的老师。
But of course, if you actually implemented that as policy, you would have schools and teachers now focused on just boosting test scores and teaching to the test. And presumably, you might not actually get the benefit of what you are hoping to get, which is great teaching, not just great test scores. Now that's quite right. I mean, I think that's an important caution that you have to think about in this context. So if you use test score based measures to evaluate teachers, it's possible that you will get a lot of teaching to the test. Now the way I view it again from a scientific point of view is it's an empirical question. To what extent when you have incentive systems where you reward teachers based on their productivity is measured by tests,
但当然，如果你真的将其作为政策实施，你就会让学校和老师现在只专注于提高考试成绩和应试教育。据推测，你可能实际上并没有得到你所希望得到的利益，那就是伟大的教学，而不仅仅是伟大的考试成绩。现在这很对。我的意思是，我认为这是一个重要的警告，你必须在这种背景下考虑。因此，如果你使用基于考试成绩的指标来评估教师，你可能会得到大量的应试教育。现在，我再次从科学的角度来看待它，这是一个经验问题。当你拥有基于考试衡量的生产力来奖励教师的激励系统时，在多大程度上
to what extent do you get unproductive behavior? And if you do, can you do things to combat that? So give you a very simple example. If we're worried that teachers do things that lead to unproductive teaching to the test in the short run, that just artificially boosts your test scores at the end of the current year. But it doesn't lead to persistent learning. One thing we might be able to do is look at your test scores then in the next grade or the year after and ask, does it seem like these students are continuing to do better even
你会得到非生产性的行为？如果确实如此，你能做些什么来对抗它吗？所以我给你一个非常简单的例子。如果我们担心老师做的事情会导致短期内非生产性的应试教育，这只是人为地提高了你当前学年结束时的考试成绩。但这并不能带来持续的学习。我们可以做的一件事是看看你在下一年级或之后一年的考试成绩，并问，这些学生在离开你的课堂后，
in the years after they leave your classroom? And if they are, then maybe you are actually teaching them something that's valuable. So we're going to reward the teachers who have these persistent impacts rather than the teachers who only have short-term impacts. All of that said, I don't think the policy solution here is some kind of algorithmic thing where we just say we're going to look at your students' test scores and determine your employment and promotion outcomes purely based on that. I view this more as useful information that principles or other managers that they should incorporate into decisions that they're making and give them the leeway
在几年里似乎还在继续做得更好吗？如果是这样，那么也许你实际上是在教给他们一些有价值的东西。所以我们将奖励那些有这种持续影响的老师，而不是那些只有短期影响的老师。话虽如此，我不认为这里的政策解决方案是某种算法，我们只是说我们将查看你学生的考试成绩，并完全基于此来决定你的就业和晋升结果。我更多地将其视为校长或其他管理者应该纳入他们正在做出的决策中的有用信息，并给他们余地
to do that. Another policy domain that I ask to ask about is housing. For example, if younger kids do better than older kids when they move to new neighborhoods, should housing vouchers be focused on families with the youngest children? We are using our data to identify neighborhoods that would be affordable to low-income families, but deliver much better outcomes for their kids. So think of these as places that are basically opportunity bargains. They are places that have good outcomes yet are still affordable.
去这样做。我询问的另一个政策领域是住房。例如，如果年幼的孩子在搬到新社区时比年长的孩子表现得更好，住房券是否应该集中在有最年幼孩子的家庭身上？我们正在利用我们的数据来确定对低收入家庭负担得起，但能为他们的孩子带来更好结果的社区。所以把这些看作是基本上是机会便宜货的地方。它们是结果良好但仍然负担得起的地方。
And so what we're doing is providing families when they come into apply for housing voucher, information about these opportunity bargain areas. We're providing assistance to those families in the form of rental brokers, basically helping them go to those places, look for housing in those places, and we're recruiting landlords in those areas to encourage them to rent their houses to tenants, simplifying the inspection process, simplifying the paperwork, and so forth. And the whole goal of this is without spending any extra money on the vouchers, try to basically achieve more bank for the buck by helping families move to those places.
所以我们正在做的是，当家庭来申请住房券时，向他们提供有关这些机会便宜货区域的信息。我们正在以租赁经纪人的形式为这些家庭提供援助，基本上帮助他们去那些地方，在那些地方寻找住房，我们正在那些地区招募房东，鼓励他们把房子租给租户，简化检查流程，简化文书工作等等。而这一切的目标是，在不额外花费住房券资金的情况下，通过帮助家庭搬到那些地方，基本上尝试实现更高的性价比。
And so, you know, the idea is to use the research to try to then make policy changes that will allow us to achieve better outcomes. Just one other, you know, angle on that, which is important. This whole study is focused on families with young kids given our finding that helping people move when they're much older really doesn't have much of an impact. So another way in which you can see the research directly informing policy design. I'm wondering if one concern that is sometimes raised in terms of sort of the geographic distribution of mobility and the policy solutions that might follow from it is, you know, so let's say,
所以，你知道，这个想法是利用研究来尝试做出政策改变，这将使我们能够实现更好的结果。关于这一点，还有一点，这很重要。考虑到我们的发现，即帮助人们在年龄大得多时搬家确实没有太大影响，整个研究都集中在有年幼孩子的家庭上。所以这是你可以看到研究直接为政策设计提供信息的另一种方式。我想知道，在地理流动性分布和可能随之而来的政策解决方案方面，有时会提出的一个担忧是，你知道，所以假设，
for example, you look at the Los Angeles data, you told me, and one of the policy implications that comes from this is, can we get the kid who's growing up in watts to move a couple of miles to be growing up in Compton and potentially have better outcomes? And let's assume for a second that you actually had empirical data that showed you that this was actually possible to do and the outcomes actually would be better. Is that actually solving the problem? Because it doesn't actually solve the problem what's happening in what? It's great for the kids whom you're moving out, but what about for the kids who are left behind?
例如，你查看洛杉矶的数据，你告诉我的，由此产生的一个政策含义是，我们能否让在瓦茨长大的孩子搬几英里到康普顿长大，并可能获得更好的结果？让我们假设一下，你实际上有经验数据表明这实际上是可能的，而且结果实际上会更好。这真的解决了问题吗？因为它并没有真正解决瓦茨正在发生的问题？这对你搬出去的孩子来说很好，但那些被留下的孩子呢？
So let me say that's an excellent point. Let me say a few things on that. So first, I think we actually don't just need to assume that it would lead to better outcomes for the kids. We have direct data now looking at exactly those types of moves that shows very clearly that earlier a child moves from an environment like Watts to the nearby place with lower rates of incarceration. They are going to have a much lower probability of getting incarcerated themselves. Now, is that really solving the problem?
所以让我说这是一个极好的观点。让我说几件事。首先，我认为我们实际上不需要仅仅假设它会为孩子们带来更好的结果。我们现在有直接的数据，准确地观察了这些类型的搬迁，非常清楚地表明，一个孩子从像瓦茨这样的环境搬到附近监禁率较低的地方越早。他们自己被监禁的可能性就会低得多。现在，这真的解决了问题吗？
Of course, it's solving the problem for that given child, but are you solving a problem societally? So, I look at it in two steps. So, first of all, many low-income families already move across neighborhoods in a given year. Something like one in five low-income families moves houses in a given year. So, the way we should think about this is not so much that we're going to take a family that was going to stay in a given place permanently, uproot them and move them somewhere else, but rather, at the point that they're moving for whatever other reason, let's potentially encourage them to make a more informed choice that might improve their
当然，它解决了那个特定孩子的问题，但你在社会层面上解决了一个问题吗？所以，我分两步来看。首先，许多低收入家庭在一年内已经在社区之间搬迁。大约五分之一的低收入家庭在一年内搬家。所以，我们应该这样思考这个问题，不是说我们要带走一个本来会永久留在某个地方的家庭，把他们连根拔起搬到别处，而是，在他们因为任何其他原因搬家的时候，让我们潜在地鼓励他们做出一个更明智的选择，这可能会改善他们的
kids outcomes in the loan. And that, to me me seems like a natural thing to do, just enable people to make the best choice as possible. But then the deeper problem you point to is that are you really solving anything in places like Watts, where you have very adverse outcomes, simply by helping people move around? And I think the answer to that is of course, no, the solution at the end of the day, it's not a scalable solution to just move everyone.
孩子长期的结果。对我来说，这似乎是一件自然而然的事情，只是让人们能够做出尽可能最好的选择。但你指出的更深层次的问题是，仅仅通过帮助人们搬来搬去，你真的在瓦茨这样的地方解决了任何问题吗？我认为答案当然是否定的，归根结底，仅仅搬走每个人并不是一个可扩展的解决方案。
You're never gonna move everyone out of Watts or a given city to another place, nor should you try to. Ultimately, of course, you have to think about what you can do in a given place to improve outcomes. And so this is where a lot of where we're headed in the policy domain is not just the moving to opportunity approach that I described,
你永远不会把每个人都从瓦茨或某个城市搬到另一个地方，也不应该尝试这样做。最终，当然，你必须考虑在某个地方能做些什么来改善结果。所以这就是我们在政策领域前进的很多方向，不仅仅是我描述的搬迁到机会的方法，
but actually partnerships with other organizations to evaluate and scale up programs that might improve outcomes in a given area. We're in conversations with groups that provide mentoring services, so think of programs like Big Brothers, Big Sisters, or My Brothers Keeper, which specifically for Black men, try to provide role models and mentoring. And there's a question of whether you can scale up and design those programs in a way that
而是实际上与其他组织建立伙伴关系，以评估和扩大可能改善特定地区结果的项目。我们正在与提供指导服务的团体进行对话，所以想想像“大哥哥大姐姐”或“我的兄弟守护者”这样的项目，它们专门针对黑人男性，试图提供榜样和指导。有一个问题是，你是否可以以一种能够真正改变这些特定地区结果的方式来扩大和设计这些项目。
will really change outcomes in those particular areas. A third potential policy domain, given we're talking about incarceration, is changes in criminal justice that could potentially have significant effects in places like this. So I absolutely agree. You need to think about policy solutions both in place, in tandem with potentially giving families better opportunities to choose where to live. When it comes to higher education, which is of course where you work, you found that some universities tend to be better than others in increasing income mobility amongst their students. With schools at these, and what can we learn from them?
鉴于我们正在谈论监禁，第三个潜在的政策领域是刑事司法方面的变革，这可能会在这样的地方产生重大影响。所以我完全同意。你需要考虑在当地的政策解决方案，同时潜在地给家庭更好的选择居住地的机会。当谈到高等教育时，这当然是你工作的地方，你发现一些大学在提高学生收入流动性方面往往比其他大学更好。学校在这些方面，我们能从中学到什么？
Is there a policy prescription here? Yeah, so higher education, I think, is another domain. So just to connect these various pieces, the way I look at mobility is kind of a pipeline from birth to adulthood. And so we spent a lot of time focusing on elementary education, kindergarten, neighborhood experience as you grow up. And then of course you get to college. And college is a place where a lot of us, I think, have the intuition that it's this domain where you're going to mix with a new group of people. It's going
这里有政策处方吗？是的，所以我认为高等教育是另一个领域。所以为了连接这些不同的部分，我看待流动性的方式是从出生到成年的管道。所以我们花了很多时间关注小学教育、幼儿园、成长过程中的社区经历。然后当然你到了大学。大学是一个我们很多人，我认为，有直觉认为它是这样一个领域，你将与一群新的人交往。它将
to be a lot more diverse than the neighborhood in which you grow up. And so forth. And so the starting point to note here is that that actually is not true in the United States. So colleges are just as segregated by income as the neighborhood in which you grow up is. That is your chances of meeting someone from a different socioeconomic background in your college are just about the same as your chances of meeting someone from a different socioeconomic background in the high school that you go to. So certain colleges in America, especially the elite private institutions, have a very high representation of extremely high income students in their student body.
比你成长的社区更加多样化。等等。所以这里需要注意的起点是，这在美国实际上是不真实的。所以大学在收入方面的隔离程度和你成长的社区一样。也就是说，你在大学里遇到来自不同社会经济背景的人的机会，和你去的高中里遇到来自不同社会经济背景的人的机会几乎是一样的。所以美国的某些大学，尤其是精英私立机构，在他们的学生群体中，极高收入学生的比例非常高。
Now the consequence of that coming back to the question about mobility is you can't, in a mechanical sense, contribute a lot to upward mobility. If you don't have a lot of low income kids to begin with, right? Harvard mechanically cannot be helping a lot of low income kids climb the income ladder, because there aren't that many low income kids at Harvard, Stanford, Princeton, Yale, etc. to begin with. In contrast, if you look at a set of mid-tier public schools, think of places like the City University of New York or California State Colleges, we find that these colleges in an accounting sense
现在，回到关于流动性的问题，其后果是，你不能在机械意义上对向上流动做出很大贡献。如果你一开始就没有很多低收入的孩子，对吧？哈佛在机械上不可能帮助很多低收入孩子攀登收入阶梯，因为哈佛、斯坦福、普林斯顿、耶鲁等学校一开始就没有那么多低收入孩子。相比之下，如果你看看一组中等水平的公立学校，想想纽约城市大学或加州州立学院这样的地方，我们发现这些大学在会计意义上
actually have the highest rates of socioeconomic mobility. And as a result, if you ask how many kids are starting out in a poor family and moving up in the income distribution, it's these mid-tier public schools where you see a lot of that happening. We began this conversation, Raj, by talking about your own life. And I actually want to end the conversation by going back to your own life as well, because I think your own life story in some ways is very instructive about many of the ideas we've talked about today.
实际上拥有最高的社会经济流动率。因此，如果你问有多少孩子从贫困家庭开始并在收入分配中向上移动，正是这些中等水平的公立学校，你看到了很多这种情况发生。拉杰，我们以谈论你自己的生活开始了这次谈话。我实际上想通过回到你自己的生活来结束这次谈话，因为我认为你自己的生活故事在某些方面对于我们今天谈论的许多想法非常有启发性。
As I was preparing for the interview and I was reading up some things about your life, I remember the story about the philosopher Bertrand Russell. He grew up in a family of writers and he assumed when he was a kid that everyone wrote books. At one point Russell meets someone and if I'm remembering the story correctly I think it's a gardener, and he's astonished to find the man is not an author. And I thought of that story when I heard that as prolific as you are,
当我准备采访并阅读一些关于你生活的事情时，我记得哲学家伯特兰·罗素的故事。他在一个作家家庭长大，小时候他以为每个人都写书。有一次罗素遇到一个人，如果我没记错故事的话，我想是一个园丁，他惊讶地发现这个人不是作家。当我听到你虽然多产，
you were the last person in your family to get an academic paper published. Is that actually true? Yes, that is actually true. And I actually think I remember my father telling me the story about Berkern Russell when I was a kid. So I come from a family of academics. I have two older sisters, both of whom are researchers as well.
但你是家里最后一个发表学术论文的人时，我想到了那个故事。那是真的吗？是的，那确实是真的。而且我实际上认为我记得我小时候父亲给我讲过关于伯特兰·罗素的故事。所以我来自一个学术家庭。我有两个姐姐，她们也都是研究人员。
And so I was the last one in my family to get a PhD in publisher paper. And so it was definitely in the air in the water, so to speak, around me. And as I've talked about through various examples empirically, I think exposure environment plays a huge role, and I absolutely see that in the work that I'm doing. And I think that is the deeper truth to the story, your own life story, but also the work that you've been doing. When we think about excellence, we think of Rache, Tey Makarth, Eugenius, we imagine the lonely climber on top of the mountain, but in reality, the story
所以我家里最后一个拿到博士学位并发表论文的人。所以这绝对是在我周围的空气中，可以说是在水中。正如我通过各种经验例子所谈到的那样，我认为接触环境起着巨大的作用，我绝对在我所做的工作中看到了这一点。我认为这是那个故事的更深层真理，你自己的生活故事，也是你一直在做的工作。当我们想到卓越时，我们会想到拉杰·切蒂，我们想象山顶上孤独的攀登者，但实际上，你描绘的故事
you're painting is much closer to the ideal, Isaac Newton's ideal. If I've seen further, it's because I stand on the shoulders of giants. That's absolutely right. And I think Shankar, that was made most evident to me, actually, in thinking about my extended family, where I see the many different experiences
更接近理想，艾萨克·牛顿的理想。如果我看得更远，那是因为我站在巨人的肩膀上。那绝对是对的。而且我认为尚卡尔，这对我来说最明显，实际上是在思考我的大家庭时，在那里我看到了我们因成长环境而拥有的许多不同经历。
that we've had as a result of the environments in which we grew up. So in particular, as you might know, the many different experiences that we've had as a result of the environments in which we grew up. So in particular, you might know, in Indian families growing up, especially in villages in poverty, families often shows one child to educate. And so it so happened to be in my father's family, he was the one who ended up getting higher education and ended up coming to the United States to University of Wisconsin-Madison to get a PhD. And my mom was one of the first women to become a doctor in our community in South India. Again, the only person in her family to get a higher education. And what I've seen is how those decisions have manifested themselves through the generations in our family.
所以特别地，正如你可能知道的那样，我们因成长环境而拥有的许多不同经历。所以特别地，你可能知道，在印度家庭中长大，特别是在贫困的村庄里，家庭通常选择一个孩子来接受教育。所以碰巧在我父亲的家庭里，他是那个最终接受了高等教育并最终来到美国威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校攻读博士学位的人。而我妈妈是我们南印度社区中第一批成为医生的女性之一。同样，她是她家里唯一一个接受高等教育的人。我所看到的是这些决定如何在我们的家庭中代代相传。
So my cousins, many of whom actually have the same name as me, Raj, named after my maternal grandfather, while they all are happy in their own ways and are leading fulfilling lives, the opportunities they've had have been dramatically different with one of them living in Singapore to support his family in India. And not able to be with his kids as they're growing up. Another working kind of a difficult job in New York City,
所以我的表兄弟们，他们中许多人实际上和我名字一样，拉杰，以我外祖父的名字命名，虽然他们都以自己的方式快乐并过着充实的生活，但他们拥有的机会却截然不同，其中一个人住在新加坡以支持他在印度的家庭。并且无法在孩子们成长时陪伴他们。另一个人在纽约市做着一种困难的工作，
in kind of a manual labor sort of position. And so again, I think the opportunities I've had exactly as you said are entirely a function of the environment that I happen to have been lucky to grow up in. And I think we're probably been studying how to replicate those opportunities for others. Raj Shetty is an economist at Harvard University. Raj, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. My pleasure. This week's episode was produced by Raina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyle and Kimmelavar
在一种体力劳动岗位上。所以再次，我认为我拥有的机会，正如你所说，完全取决于我幸运地成长在其中的环境。而且我认为我们可能一直在研究如何为其他人复制这些机会。拉杰·切蒂是哈佛大学的经济学家。拉杰，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。我的荣幸。本周的节目由雷娜·科恩制作，由塔拉·博伊尔和基梅拉瓦尔编辑。
Gestress Trepo. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parts Shah, Thomas Liu and Laura Quarell, special thanks to Caitlin Herap, who recorded the kindergarten class you heard at the top of the show. Raj mentioned a tool that tracks economic mobility, neighborhood by neighborhood. You can put in your address at opportunityatlus.org. Once again, that's opportunityatlus.org. Our unsung hero this week is principal Ryan Jungi at Keystone Elementary School in Iowa. When we were trying to figure out which kindergarten classroom we wanted to visit, we looked for a school in a part of the country that has one of the
杰斯特雷斯·特雷波。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、帕茨·沙、托马斯·刘和劳拉·夸雷尔，特别感谢凯特琳·赫拉普，她录制了你在节目开头听到的幼儿园班级。拉杰提到了一个追踪经济流动性的工具，按社区划分。你可以在 opportunityatlus.org 输入你的地址。再说一遍，是 opportunityatlus.org。我们本周的无名英雄是爱荷华州基斯通小学的校长瑞安·琼吉。当我们试图弄清楚我们想参观哪个幼儿园教室时，我们寻找的是该国拥有最佳流动性记录之一的地区的一所学校。
best records of our port mobility. That's how we found Keystone Elementary in a rural part of Eastern Iowa. Principal Jungi allowed us to hang out in one of his kindergarten classrooms. Now it takes a lot to run a school and having an audio producer running about isn't high on your list of priorities, but he got on board very quickly and figured out a way to make it possible. We are grateful. If the ideas in this episode spoke to you, please consider making a donation to your local public radio station. It would mean the world to them and it would mean the world to me. To make a contribution, please go to donate.npr.org slash hidden brain.
这就是我们如何在爱荷华州东部的农村地区找到基斯通小学的原因。琼吉校长允许我们在他的一个幼儿园教室里待着。现在，经营一所学校需要很多精力，让一个音频制作人在周围跑来跑去并不是你优先事项清单上的高位，但他很快就加入了，并想出了一种使之成为可能的方法。我们很感激。如果这一集中的想法触动了你，请考虑向你当地的公共广播电台捐款。这对他们来说意义重大，对我来说也意义重大。要做出贡献，请访问 donate.npr.org/hiddenbrain。
I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是 NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。